we've had 75 or 80 year run with some
really aggressive progressive policies
they haven't worked they have enhanced
America's opportunity deficit and the
American people want a more conservative
government hi I'm Nicholas we with
reason TV and today we're talking with
Senator Mike Lee he is one of the
architects and I'd argue probably the
intellectual heavyweight of the
libertarian wing of the Republican Party
certainly in the Senate and the Tea
Party faction senator Lee thanks for
talking to us
thank you out-of-the-box the
export-import bank which you've
identified as you know just kind of an
exemplar of cronyism looks like it's
finally on its last legs do you think it
is going not it that it's not going to
be reauthorized and if so what does that
tell us about the the kind of spirit of
reform both in DC generally as well as
Washington there whether the Republican
Party I think there's a growing movement
in this country that is against having
government pick winners and losers in
industry and the export-import bank is
an example of this sort of thing
look when US manufacturers can obtain
financing on the open market and in the
private marketplace we ought not have a
government agency set up specifically to
do this otherwise we run the risk of
having the government pick winners and
losers in industry what what change
because just two years ago Eric Cantor
you know the former majority leader who
got primary doubt of his seat he led the
charge on the Republican side in the
house to reauthorize the export-import
bank which essentially gives financing
to foreign companies or foreign
governments to buy US products so what
happened in two years that it went from
the majority leader leading the charge
to reauthorize it to him getting bounced
to the to the curb I think there's a
growing reluctance on the part of
Americans for having government in the
business sphere if we're having
government picking winners and losers in
business people are realizing that you
know our national government has not
done a great job at managing a whole lot
of things whether you're talking about
it's management of veteran's health care
or whether you're talking about its
management of funds set aside or that
we're supposed to be set aside for
Social Security or for Medicare it has
done a bad job of a lot of things and we
shouldn't be giving it more power we
shouldn't be turning it into a business
that's what business is for that's what
the free market is for what you know you
you in a lot of your past Commons or
your continuing comments you take aim at
a lot of Republican kind of policy
mistakes as well as Democratic ones do
you see the Obama administration as more
or less a continuation of the George
Bush years in terms of growing
government interference in the economy
reckless foreign policy reckless
disregard for American Civil Liberties
you've been outspoken and you know
excesses on the NSA you refused to vote
in favor of the National Defense
reauthorization because it did not
actually protect people from basically
being killed by the president if he so
chose do you see a lot of continuity
between Bush and Obama and then kind of
characters like you as kind of standing
up with a different set of politics I
would certainly say that civil liberties
have suffered under this administration
so yet a lot of people who were
complaining about the direction we were
headed in under the last administration
well I think we've seen more government
surveillance under this administration
and I think it's troubling to a lot of
Americans yeah I was one of the first
Republicans to join in the effort to
oppose the reauthorization of the
Patriot Act I voted against the
reauthorization of the FISA Amendments
Act and I did so at a time when not only
were there very very few Republicans
willing to do that we weren't even
allowed to talk about all the reasons
why we were voting against it because it
was still classified now that a lot of
that information has been d-class
Declassified it's become a little bit
easier to talk about is Edward Snowden
in your mind is he a patriot or a hero
or is he a traitor or does it not matter
what he is as long as we have the
information that he's helped make
available yeah look he's not my focus my
focus is on the policies my focus is on
the fact that Americans have reason to
be concerned about our government
that wants to spy on it that wants to
monitor them and Americans are
understandably concerned about having
their metadata collected on the scale
that it is on having the content of
their electronic communications also
subject to collection and subject to
subsequent review do you think the
Republicans are going to take over the
Senate in the fall and hold a house I
mean will we be looking at another GOP
Congress come November I do think that's
going to happen and it's going to be
close but I think they're the odds are
very much in our favor for the
Republicans taking over the set but what
has to change because obviously the
Republicans lost the Senate within
recent memory and they lost them regain
the house
what what is the Republican message that
is going to resonate with the American
population I think what resonates with
the public is that we're there as a
party we are there to fight for the
American people were there to address
America's growing opportunity deficit
and you know this deficit shows up in
three and three levels of our economy it
shows up in the form of immobility among
the poor insecurity among the middle
class and crony is privileged at the top
of the economic ladder and I think that
as Republicans as conservatives we will
fight for economic opportunity fight to
get government in the right space so
that the American people can do what
they do best do you primarily you
identify as a conservative not as a
libertarian and is that a meaningful
distinction to you or you know what
what's the problem with libertarianism I
have been accused of generally call
myself a conservative sometimes a
constitutional conservative my focus is
on the fact that when we maintain a
consistent effort to restrain the
government's power and its influence its
role to those powers identified in the
Constitution that's where we strike the
right balance between what kind of
government we need and what kind of
government we don't want and you've
you've written in a book that you
published in 2011 as well as in your
continuing work about an important
aspect is what you know what level of
government should be administering
what assuming a program makes sense or a
policy makes sense should it be at the
federal level should it be at the state
level should it be at the local level
talk a little bit about your federalism
principles because uncertain level you
know I in certain issues you're like
yeah the federal government should not
even be involved in this there should be
a state and local issue so for instance
recently and if I'm mistaken correct me
you've said that you know with things
like that the definition of marriage
that can be remanded to the states or to
a lower level of government not that it
can be remanded in those days it's that
it that is state power kind it always
was state power it never was never
should be federal so that's where the
power is what what are the what about
drug legalization or drug policy and
things like online gambling you've
recently introduced a law saying that no
that's something that the federal
government should really dictate online
gambling policy and that seems to be
kind of a contradiction with the idea of
I I assume you think it's okay for
states to decide on gambling yes if it's
horse-racing or something like that yeah
it's fine for states should be the
entities that decide questions of
gambling on gambling that takes place
within a state but where you've got
gambling that takes place online the
online world is an interstate and an
international network of wires and
that's why it really becomes an
interstate exercise the minute you take
it online and so really if you think
about it the the this is actually a
necessary step to take in order to
respect each state's right to decide
whether or to what extent to allow
gambling and that it's necessary in
order to preserve each state's right to
decide that otherwise you could have one
state here they're authorizing gambling
and and if no one is able to prohibit
internet gambling then people in every
state would be able to gamble that'd be
a horrible outcome though I mean
shouldn't it be up to the individual to
just say yeah I want to you know I want
to bet on a sports game or I want to bet
on a I want to bet on the Preakness even
though I lived 3,000 miles away from the
horse track yeah here again I'm
approaching this from the standpoint of
federalism yeah I don't think it's the
federal government's job to say that
every state must recognize
the worse at the federal government's
job to say no state may authorize
gambling the this is an appropriate step
toward making sure that each state can
decide on its own what kind of health
safety and and morals legislation it
wants to come up with and the best way
for the federal government to respect
the sovereignty of the states is to put
in place legislation like this so that
one state's law can't easily almost
automatically be circumvented you you've
been involved in the past couple of
years and two of the great kind of
political spectacles and and I don't
mean that to diminish their impact but
you know both the filibuster against the
NSA when John Brennan was being
nominated for CIA director and then also
the the kind of filibuster about health
care defunding Obamacare which helped
precipitate a government shutdown how
you know how do you decide those are the
things that I'm going to the mat for and
certainly on the latter one you took a
lot of hits both in the press but also
in polls and things like that how do you
decide which of those you go with and
then how do you think they turned out
well obviously if people are concerned
about drones they're running about the
use of drones and not just spying
through the use of drones but also
attacks on American citizens Rand Paul
was trying to get a pretty simple answer
out of the administration
he ended up feeling like he got an
answer out of it as a result of that now
with respect to the effort to defund
Obama care this was a president who had
announced as of July 2013 that he wasn't
going to follow the affordable care act
as written Obamacare that the law itself
wasn't ready to be implemented as
written and so he effectively rewrote
several provisions of Obamacare saying
individuals will have to comply with the
individual mandate but corporations
won't have to comply with the employer
mandate this is wrong at that stage when
a president does something like that
Congress's options are relatively
limited but Congress has the tool that
James Madison described in Federalist 58
the the tool that can be found in the
power of the purse and so my response to
all that was look at
president doesn't want to implement the
law as written if the president is
telling us that law is not ready to be
implemented we're not going to fund his
implementation of this law and we had a
defunded for at least a year I think
that was a reasonable response and
indeed a necessary one and I predicted
at the time that if we didn't do
something like that that the president's
behavior would not only continue but
that it would expand now since then we
know that he has rewritten that law
dozens of times he doesn't have the
power to do that it's difficult for the
courts to remedy this short of
impeachment and removal there is no
other remedy that Congress can take and
we know impeachment removals not going
to happen do you know this was the
appropriate response it was what was
inappropriate was for the President to
say unless you're willing to fund
everything in government I won't let you
fund anything in government and I'll
shut down the government that was wrong
do you think it was a failure of nerve
among other opponents of Obamacare not
to you know not to go to the mat on that
because it you know it was interesting a
lot of people were you know it it seems
to be less about the principle and more
about kind of the pragmatics know that
it would do you know you if you were
involved in that you would suffer among
voters or something like that but in
fact I mean the principle seems pretty
clear yeah I think that principle seems
pretty clear and it was disheartening to
me it was disappointing to me that you
had some Republicans actually join with
the president and saying oh guys like
Mike Lee and Ted Cruz
shut down the government when it was
literally the president it was the
president who decided to shut down the
government it was the president who said
unless you've found everything in
government I won't leave on anything in
government I'll shut it down all of a
sudden they're blaming this on two
relatively junior US senators looking
good looking good looking dashing with a
future ahead of them here you had said
that you know so the GOP will likely
take over Congress in the fall can we
afford another GOP Congress the last
time the GOP controlled both houses of
Congress they also controlled the White
House but federal spending under you
know if between about 2001 and about
2008 or so federal spending increased by
over 50% in real terms you know federal
regulation spending on regulation
enforcement went up about 60 percent you
know what you're in favor of a balanced
budget amendment how can we how can you
tell people you know this time when the
Republic
run Congress they they will get it and
they will do it right what what you know
what message do you have to allay
people's worries I think we've seen in
recent years that the American people
want conservatism to work they want to
give it a chance we've had 75 or 80 year
run with some really aggressive
progressive policies they haven't worked
they have enhanced America's opportunity
deficit and the American people want a
more conservative government and I do
think that Republicans in both houses of
Congress are catching on to that let me
ask you about Millennials you know
everybody the millennial generation of
basically voters between about eighteen
and thirty or so they are they represent
a bigger generation or cohort than the
baby boom generation they are the future
of the country whether we like it or not
you know they're just a big hunk of
people out there currently the reason
Rupe quarterly poll found that about
twenty three percent of Millennials
identify as Republican leaning or say
the Republican compared to about forty
one percent of voters who are Republican
or lean Republican over the age of
thirty
what does the Republican Party have to
do to change it's met either change its
message or its communication to reach
young people why aren't Millennials
flocking what do Republicans have to do
to reach that generation first of all I
think Republicans need to reach out to
Millennials and explain to them that
ours is the party of conservatism and
conservatism is the movement that wants
to get the government out of your
business it wants to get the government
out of the practice of spying on you and
targeting you and lying to you
and wants to get the government out of
the practice of intergenerational wealth
this redistribution this is a problem
and you've identified it pretty well in
terms of government programs that result
in making one group pay for another
groups government program where does
abortion fit into your kind of
federalists you know kind of system is
that's something that should be decided
at the state level or where is it you
know is there a sanctity of life that
overrides the you know the ability of
states to say yeah this is okay or not
well one of the reasons I think Roe
versus Wade was wrongly decided is
because I don't think that the
Constitution makes this a federal
constitutional issue I think that by and
large this should have been an area that
was covered by state legislatures and
different state legislatures should have
been able to decide here are the
circumstances you know whether it's rape
incest life of the mother or other
circumstances you might be states should
have been able to make that decision
that also the case with say marijuana
legalization insofar as we're talking
about the the bare intrastate possession
I think that if we were starting from a
blank slate that's probably where we
should have gone because you're not
talking about an interstate shipment or
an international shipment interstate
production and distribution and so but
but since then since Roe versus Wade we
have both federalized the issue and
we've taken it away from the legislative
process and I think that that's wrong
does your faith inform your politics you
know I guess that's one question and
then should people who you know I mean
how should voters you know should they
care about a politician or a leaders
faith first of all my faith informs
everything I do it certainly informs how
I do my job how how I treat my family
how I interact with others so yeah it
informs everything I do what is the
essence of you know of kind of your
faith and it just you know is it do unto
others is it
I mean following Jesus Christ you know
that Jesus Christ the Redeemer of the
world the Son of God who took upon
himself the sins of mankind and made it
possible for us to receive forgiveness
and to be resurrected after this life as
to the second part of your question
there are many who share my faith who
don't share my view of government mm-hmm
and so I'm certainly not willing to
assume as a voter that's simply because
someone else shares my faith they're
going to get my vote so as a voter what
I look for is whether somebody shares my
view of government and its proper role
that person may or may not share my
faith that person may or may not have
any faith but what I want to know
because I'm hiring them not to be my
minister I'm hiring them to represent me
in government I want to know what they
think the proper role of government is
and if they're running for federal
office I want to know what they think
the proper role of the federal
government is how they read the
Constitution whether they see this as
sort of an open ended conversation
starter or whether they view it is
actually meaningfully restricting the
power of the federal government you know
faith in Congress I mean of the Gallup
poll just came out recently 7% of people
have a lot of confidence in Congress
these days it's a historic low ran the
reason office the question was like who
are those 7% it like well I mean have
they been in a case it's that way
yeah exactly so you know what are what
are you know it seems like there's a lot
of energy towards a libertarian a
conservative movement smaller government
how do we know that candidates and
elected officials get it you know what
you know that they are actually signing
on to limited government constitutional
government and responsible government I
think most of the time we know whether
they get it based on what they tell us
the battle lines are becoming a little
clearer every day when people are
learning what a true limited government
conservative looks like what a true
limited government conservative is
willing to say and identify as as a
bright-line rule and then does that work
with somebody I mean you famously
primary day longtime incumbent or
primary primary candidates generally a
good idea even if the Challenger doesn't
win but with somebody like McDaniel
versus thad Cochran in Mississippi it's
a kind of a analogous situation is that
a place where the lines are kind of
clearly drawn where you have a guy who's
been in power for
long time always seems to be happy to go
along and get along spend a lot of money
versus a challenger is that you know
using you know talking about what they
say what candidates say is there a clear
choice there for you in in who - back in
that situation in order for the
Republican Party or any political party
for that matter to be able to lay any
claim to being a party of principle
there needs to be a robust debate within
that party and for that to occur
I think primary elections will always
need to happen